[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Joining me now is
Priyanka Vergadia, a customer
engineer at Google
Cloud, who's going
to show us how to develop for
Kubernetes without leaving
your IDE.
Thanks, for being here.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Thank
you, for having me.
I'm going to talk about
Kubernetes and how developers
can work within
the Visual Studio
environment and deploy
applications into Kubernetes.
So let's jump right in.
SPEAKER 1: Great.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Cool.
So I have on the left
hand side my terminals,
which we're going to use
to do some deployments.
And then on the right here,
I have a Visual Studio Code.
So we're going to start off
by creating a new application.
I'll just create a
"Hello World" Node.js
application, nothing fancy.
So what's happening
here is we should
be able to see our
application created.
Once I refresh, it is
showing up my application.
I have the source files.
The front end and the back
end are the different services
that are in this application.
In the front end, we
have the 8080 port that's
listening to the front end.
It's talking to the back end
on back end service address.
And in the back end,
we have the index file
that's also talking to 8080.
So we're going to change
that to 8081 so that we
don't have a port conflict.
And then at this point, if we
go and start these services
and then just check where
we are in our terminal,
we're at the right place
in the front end folder.
And we want to do the same
for our back end as well.
So I'm going to go into
the right folder, which
is the "Hello World"
Node.js application too.
And then so we're now in back
end and front end folders.
Now, if we run NPM
install, that's
going to get us all
the dependencies
that it needs to run both
our front end and back end
services.
And then once that is done, we
need to start these services.
So our back end is
running on 8081,
and our front end's
running on 8080.
So we're ready to
test our application.
Our back end is on 8081,
and our front end is on 8080
talking to our back end.
So we have an application that's
running through Visual Studio
Code.
Now at this point, if I wanted
to deploy this application
into GKE, I would first
need a cluster to create.
And then once the
cluster is created,
then I can start deploying
this application.
So let's see how we can create
a cluster from within Visual
Studio Code.
I have the extension
for Visual Studio
Code, called GKE extension.
And once you download
that extension,
you'll start to
see your projects
and your clusters in
your IDE environment.
I'm going to just use one
of the current projects
and create a cluster
in the current project.
So my current project
is pv-cube-dem.
And so we'll set
that as a project ID.
And then it gives me an
option to select the zones.
And then here, we're just going
to say test as a cluster name.
And then there's
the number of nodes
that you want to create
that you can change and then
also the machine types.
We're just going to go with
the standard and click Create.
Once I do that, it takes
maybe three to four minutes
to actually create the cluster.
It's spinning up
all these instances
in Google Cloud for you.
And if I refresh
this, you should
be able to see that it's
starting to bring up the test
cluster right here.
It's orange, because
it's not set up yet.
So give it a few minutes,
and it starts to set up.
At this point, we're going to
just use for the demo purpose
a cluster that I
already have created.
And we'll go through the
demo using that cluster.
Now, once I have the
cluster, I'm ready to deploy.
And I need a Skaffold YAML to
actually deploy in the cluster.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
And for those who
might not have heard
of Skaffold, what is that?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: So
Skaffold is basically
a command line tool
that lets you define
your Kubernetes manifest.
It also defines the
container registries.
And then for the back
end, and the front,
and especially for
our application here,
so if you have a large
number of services
that are running in
your application,
you would define your container
registry addresses in there.
It would pick up
from those addresses
and deploy your service in GKE.
SPEAKER 1: Great.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yeah.
So let's see an example of that.
So I'm just first going
to go through deployment.
I think I forgot
to set the cluster,
so let's first set this cluster.
Once it is set, then
we're going to deploy.
Take the deploy, and do that.
It's starting to deploy.
While it's deploying, let's
look at our Skaffold YAML.
This is the YAML I was
talking about where
you have the back end,
and the front end,
and the gcr.io addresses,
which is the container registry
address, and then the
manifest for you Kubernetes.
And it seems like we have
our application deployed,
so let's see the IP address.
That's the IP address
of our application.
It's the one that
we just created.
And we see that the application
is working on port 4,000.
So our front end is
talking to our back end.
Both of them now deployed
on a GKE cluster.
So we did all of
that from our IDE.
And yeah.
SPEAKER 1: That's fantastic.
I guess the next step
that I would think of
is making changes to,
let's say, our back end
without affecting our front end.
So for example, what if I
want to test to make sure
that my change doesn't break
anything without needing
to redeploy and rebuild.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
That's a great point
because, in a
development lifecycle,
that's the biggest hurdle.
You develop, you test, and
then you want to deploy that.
But the test stage is
a very critical stage,
so you would use something
called TelePresence for that.
And TelePresence is,
again, a command line tool
that helps you create a proxy.
So in this case, in this
example, what we're going to do
is create a proxy and
create and run our back end
on local machine.
And then our front
end would continue
to run on our GKE
cluster in production.
So we're able to test the
changes to our back end,
but our front end stays intact.
SPEAKER 1: OK, great.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
So let's see that.
Yeah.
So in this case here, so
when you come out of this--
and let's see where we are--
I want to go into
the application
that we just deployed,
which is this.
And let's make a
little bit of a change
here in our front
end application
so that we can use
a little bit of a--
so I just called it
Version 2 for our back end.
And at this point, if I run
my TelePresence command, which
is nothing but it
creates a proxy,
and it's going to
run it on port--
so here it is.
It's forwarding the ports now.
And if we go test our back
end on our local machine,
that's going to Version 2.
And it should work the same way
from our front end, as well.
So that's pretty
much how it works.
SPEAKER 1: Very impressive.
So we were not only
able to see you
being able to redeploy
using your local IDE to GKE
using Cloud Code and
Skaffold, but you were also
able to make changes locally
to a single service, test it,
and then again redeploy
to GKE once we're using--
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Pretty powerful, yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, TelePresence.
OK.
Well, thank you so much
again for joining us.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Thank you for having me.
[MUSIC PLAYING]